Marking.
Annette, good morning.
Good morning. How are you?
Good, good, alone today. Andy and Andrea and Ira, yeah.
Oh, yeah, I was gonna say it's a it's a holiday, right?
You got that that new that new initiation working on the first holiday. No, thank you. Thank you for working today. We definitely appreciate it. Because again, it is one of those areas where we are 24 by 7 through 65. But you know, we all also like to have our time off when when we're supposed to. So thank you. Thank you for working today.
Yeah.
I'm, yeah.
Technically, I'm the holiday offering for today.
There you go. There you go. I used to be like that too, like, because I live away from where my family's at. Like, I moved away, like, just, you know, back in the day where you had to like move places to get career opportunities. Now I work in a state, work from home, and then my company is actually closer to where I grew up.
had at the end of the day, corporately. But yeah, I seem to be that person too. Like I would, I'm like, I'm not doing anything for Easter, like, but I would always be like, but I'm gonna go home for Christmas. Like I'm going home for Christmas. I'm gonna need that time off, but like I'll work any other holiday because I'm not doing anything else. So.
Yeah.
Club.
We'll see if, have they been joining the calls?
Sage.
Yeah, I'm talking to Jim earlier and I've asked if he'll gonna join today and he said yes.
Okay, I think it's supposed to be, so he said, Jim said he was going to have, I think the other guy's name's Dan. Is that his name? Dan, is he joined, he's the one who's supposed to be joining the service calls, and then Jim said he's going to start joining more for QBRs and like things like that. So we need, so Dan doesn't show up today, then we'll have a.
Yeah, Dan.
Yeah.
Mmh.
a conversation as well.
Yeah, I think, as per the guys here for MSK, Dan is not available today, so...
Income.
So, I'm expecting just Jim.
PH.
Yeah, we'll see because Jim, we I thought we had like we were doing this new cadence of.
Mm.
Service team's gonna be with the service team, so we have that overly, like the operationally, we're super secure, and then Jim only needs to pop in 'cause this is so sometimes he doesn't, you know, come to the call, so send him an email and then address it to Dan and him, and then ask if they're gonna be joining.
Or maybe just address it to Jim and say, hey, Jim, I saw the team said that Dan's out today. Are you going to be joining the call or should I get this rescheduled for when Dan will be back?
Okay.
I.
Just because Jim's one of those two that he'll come back and he'll be like, I told you guys I was only going to be joining these quarterly. Like, so I could see him saying that.
Yeah.
I am trying to get him to come to build it though, because he essentially...
He's not too far from there, so I was hoping to talk with him.
Yeah.
Yeah, I've sent it, so let's wait for the response.
So you watch basketball?
Yeah, New York, New York for doing, yeah, just one point.
Yeah, just that crazy. Yeah, it's crazy, bro. I haven't even been like, and I do like basketball. So like my, and my son's been back for college. So like whenever the last game, I was like just getting back from the event and he had it on. So like I was watching it whenever they shot it up. And then he was telling me, he's like, yeah, it's like the greatest comeback in history. And I was like, wow, this is awesome.
Um, yeah, so it's cool. I grew up playing basketball, so I like, I like basketball.
Yeah, crazy, uh, crazy finish.
Yeah, and then the funniest thing, I keep seeing videos of Char, what's his name? The guy, the kid who played Spider-Man, Char Laroia, I can't even think of his name right now. But he's like the biggest Knicks fan. So like I was watching a video yesterday. So it's so funny to see because there's so many celebrities out there too. And then on the internet after like all the celebrity like videos.
Yeah, yeah.
and how they're all like just getting excited. But him specifically, like he was walking by and he's dating one of the Kardashians as well. So he was like walking by and he basically just started freaking out. He was like, got on the grounds like one, two, three, 4. And then he gets in a circle of like all these people and he takes his shirt off.
PH.
Oh.
Yeah.
It's like, bro, he's like acting like a college kid right now, like, like his favorite team, but like, that's just how you know people get about their teams, like, like you rage out when your team's gonna win the championship, like...
But.
Yeah.
And.
So yeah, it's going to be cool. And then on the other side of it, just to give you some, I don't know if in the Philippines is gambling big at all? Do people like bet on sports or is it even legal to do something like that? Okay, yeah. Yeah, so.
Yeah, yeah, it's legal, uh, some people does that.
So there's this other, I was out to dinner with some friends and there was like some people from this guy's gym was there. And so I didn't know the person at all, but he was telling this story how basically the Spurs, so the Spurs are in as well, you know, this probably. And
And he like took basically somebody, like he has an actual bookie that he like will put his bets with. And somebody at the gym gave him $100. And he was like, there was no way that the Spurs were going to make it to the finals because this was like back in the day. And he was like, I'm like, and he's a pretty like straight edge, like the one guy was talking about him. And he's like, he's a super like kind of like a straight edge kid. And he was like, yeah, he's like, I basically was just
Like, I don't think the Spurs are going to make it. So I just never gave it to my bookie. And it was mostly because like he just never like got around to like to doing it in general. And but he was like, yeah, they're not going to win. And so now they're in the final. So like I keep thinking about like that conversation because he said he will pay the guy out like.
He.
he was also telling me like his family is super rich and they like are one of like the sponsors for like the Dallas Stars. So I think the guy's like good for the money, like on the back end, because I think the payout will be like $700 or something like that, whatever the odds, the odds are. So like, but I keep thinking about that as well. I was like, if the Spurs end up winning, I'm like, this, this kid is going to have to pay out of his pocket because he didn't.
Really.
No.
Ohh.
Yeah, yeah.
You have $100, and this is all I got.
Yeah.
So, yeah, that that's what those are my those are my basketball stories that I have for you.
Well, there's no response yet from Jim, so...
Okay, yeah, we can hop, that's all I was saying, and then if that Dan guy's out, but that's my recommendation for you is just try to build that relationship with Dan. That's what Jim wants as well. He kind of wants to be more hands-off. He wants it to operationally be handled with service delivery, and then him and I can connect, come on QVRs, and then we can get that consistency and that flow going.
Mhm.
And I think we'll be able to slowly grow the account that if we do it that way. So that's your, so make Dan your best friend and I'll join these calls as much as I can as well.
Yeah.
Yeah, for sure.
Yeah, but Dan is always asking me to add Jim to the conversation. Not sure, I'm not sure why, but...
Okay, all right, that's why, so maybe I think maybe we all just need to have a realignment. I think Jim, so Jim's also one of those, I think he kind of just kind of floats along. Like a lot of the times I talk to him and he's like on the road or he's like doing something, right? So like I honestly think we just need, and this happens with our clients as well. Like you'll notice, like they don't always.
Mhm.
communicate internally the way that we would like them to. And you'll think, like you will have this assumption that, oh, they've talked about this, but they've never had that conversation, like at all, right? So yeah, and I'm okay with coming in here and telling Dan that like that's what the expectation is from Jim. And then if Jim needs to come on and if Jim.
Yeah.
Mmh.
strives to say something, right? Let me let me handle it. Like, well, we'll go through, but that's the best way. That's how the like the relationships and making sure the account is consistent. Like that's going to be the best, the best way so that everybody is like actively understands what's going on holistically.
Yeah.
on the account with their existing bandwidth. So we'll get there.
Yeah, for sure.
Yeah.
Yep.
Yeah, okay. Thanks. See ya.
Thanks, Marky. Bye.